I noticed here you've got a post that
says you don't like the word simp can
you explain that like what was the
contention with that with the word simp
yeah that I don't like the word simp I
think I was saying that I don't like the
simps from uh certain certain influen
sorry I'm misreading it says is there
anything more annoying than a sin yeah
okay so I don't like simps uh how would
you define a
simp
um the generalization of what a s is
somebody who says loves everything of
one person I don't know why how would
you define a s somebody who well I'm
asking you because because you said that
you have an issue with the uh simps of
the world out there so I'm just
wondering how do you define a
s I have an issue with people who
will argue in favor of somebody without
thinking of through the issues it's
somebody that will
um but is that the definition of a simp
you said there's is there anything more
annoying than a simp so trying to
understand what your definition of a s
is yeah I'm trying to articulate what a
simp is I think we all kind of know what
it is and I had never needed to
articulate it the what is you find them
annoying so you must know what they are
yeah absolutely I think we all know what
simps are so what is a s somebody who
follows somebody to the ends of the
Earth I don't know what to how to how to
name
that so you don't know what a s
is okay well actually you have the
definition posted below here it says
what is a simp men simp is slaying
insult for men who are seen as too
attentive and submissive to women
especially out of failed hope of winning
some entitled sexual attention or
activity from them I think it's an
unfair exchange I think when it's a guy
that does something for a woman and gets
an unfair Exchange in return that's what
my definition of a simp is a guy that
doesn't have a lot of dignity for
himself um I think a lot of men
influencers also have male simps I think
that a s is not necessarily just a
manree oh i' agree yeah there's there's
definitely guys out there that like
worship male influencers for sure
absolutely I think that that post was
was inspired by a male sing for another
male oh okay so it was male sipping for
another male sure got it do you think a
man can s for women though of course and
they
do what would be an example of a man
siing for a woman the same in what you
just described a man who will like an
unfair exchange absolutely so isn't a
23-year-old getting with a 40-year-old
with four kids who's older and already
has children an unfair exchange to the
23-year-old if the 23-year-old would
like that to happen how is that unfair
he's getting something in return
well from an outsider's perspective
because it's the outsider that calls
somebody a simp so by your definition
your son would be a simp my son is not
with a 40-year-old woman so again I
would really like to leave this using
that example using that as an ex I don't
know why we need to use my kid as an
example honestly because you're a parent
and I'm trying to establish something
here if my son was happy with a woman
regardless okay if the 40-year-old woman
didn't have any children would it be the
same problem or is it the children that
you have a problem with it compound with
the problem the problem is is that she's
too old for him so what about a
50-year-old man with a 20s something
year old woman is that not too old
that's pretty routine I mean sorry not
not as routine but it's more commonly
accepted and it's a made December
relationship we all know around that way
for thousands of years because men are
success objects right and women are
Beauty objects so that exchange of the
successful older guy with a beautiful
younger woman happens and it's accepted
that's why Leonardo DiCaprio trades in
his girlfriends when they hit a certain
Line in the Sand and just gets another
model right CIO and he can do that um
lonus I forgot his first name he had
that show on
CNBC um you know who I'm talking about
no off lonus yeah Marcus lonus Marcus
lonis thank you so much yeah from the uh
he's something about an entrepreneur
show used to love to watch that show
he's married to a woman much younger
much older than him and they seem very
happy I mean listen mcon he married his
teacher that French uh did prime
minister uh there I would have the issue
with the fact that she was his teacher I
think that's that's probably it's a
little different when when you meet
somebody as an adult I again I'm married
to somebody nine years my junior that I
met as an adult um I think that's very
different if I would have been his
teacher I think this would be a very
different conversation so um in that
case I think that that that's just wrong
because of the sphere of influence that
she had over him um yeah but I don't see
listen if my kid wants to marry an older
woman that's his choice um I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna get between him what if he
wants to marry a man I'm not gonna stop
him what if he wants to you know like
it's almost drugs and cocaine and heroin
we're back to this again like what if
you said Ma I think I was I think I was
born a man when I should be a woman and
he wants to cut off his Johnson and
become a woman and call
himself Nancy would you be okay with
that would you endorse that would you
coign
that I would um I don't know how I'd
have how I'd handle it because I'm not
in that position however I have friends
who are trans and I I would not support
it for a minor if you are an adult and
this is something you choose to do that
is your choice I again I don't know how
I would handle it personally I've never
been in that situation I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're newer to the channel make sure
you hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out